كريس مسينا هو تقني كان يعمل في عدد من
الشركات وابرزها جوجل كان اول شخص يستخدم
الهاشتاج وهو مخترع هذه الاداه التي اصبحت
جزءا لا يتجزا من الحياه الاجتماعيه على
الانترنت كيف جاءتك فكره انشاء هاشتاج لو
عدنا الى عام 2007 في تلك الفتره كانت
ذروه انتشار مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فتويتر لم يكن يتمتع بالشعبيه التي نعرفها
به الان وقد ك نحن والقراصنه في وادي
السيليكون نستخدم تويتر للتواصل مع بعضنا
البعض واحد المشاكل التي كنا نواجهها هو
انه لم يكن مثيرا للاهتمام وهو في الحقيقه
ما كان يواجهه ايضا المستخدمون فبدا
العديد بالتفكير بطريقه لانشاء مجموعات
على الموقع اي وجود موضوع واحد لكل مجموعه
من الناس او لمن يهمه الامر وبدات انا
بالبحث عن حل ووجدته مستخدما بكيفيه اخرى
في موقع يتيح لاي شخص انشاء قناه لاجراء
محادثات فيها والطريقه كانت وضع اشاره
الباوند قبل الكلمه وجدت انها طريقه جيده
للناس للاتصال بخصوص موضوع ما فاقترحت
الفكره على تويتر نفسه بتغريده مؤرخه في
الث3 من اغسطس اب 2007 وكانت ردود الفعل
متنوعه فمنهم من قال انها فكره جيده ومنهم
من رفضها تماما قائلا انها تافهه لكن في
الوقت نفسه لدي صديق وكان يقوم باخذ
معلومات من مقالات اخباريه وينشرها على
تويتر وهو شيء نفعله عاده الان كان يتحدث
عن حريق سان ديجو عام 2007 وكان من الصعب
متابعه تغريداته والعثور عليها فاقترحت
عليه ان يضع هاشتاج حريق سان ديجو في كل
تغريده عن الموضوع وهكذا كل من يهمه الامر
يمكنه متابعته بل وتقليد طريقته ايضا وهذا
ما فعله بالضبط واصبحت فكره مستخدمه من
قبل العديد الى ان رايتها على اعلان في
الطريق وعندها علمت انها بدات تستخدم على
نطاق واسع وليس من قبل القراصنه
فقط